passer au thème au débat de ce club et à
quelques jours du Salon de l'Agriculture
on va parler de l'avenir de la
viticulture d'abord peut-être un mot
avec vous Michel Chapoutier comment se
porte aujourd'hui le secteur viticole en
France est-ce que c'est un secteur en
crise alors on parle souvent de crise de
surproduction s'il y a certains endroits
crises je pense qu'il y a plutôt une
crise de sous commercialisation la
question il y a des fois des produits
qui ne trouvent pas acheteurs alors que
le monde
le monde consomme et on est passé
orienté à l'export historiquement il y a
une déconsommation des vins rouges mais
même dans les régions qui sont dites
sinistrés ou la crise est plus marquée
et bien vous avez au milieu des acteurs
qui surperforment
c'est à dire que c'est assez intéressant
on a vraiment ce côté à deux vitesses en
déjà qui ont
compris un coup d'avance sur la réaction
de la demande du marché et après une
organisation des fois qui a un peu lente
à observer les marchés et réagir
la consommation je rappelle juste quand
j'ai commencé dans le métier on était à
100 litres par tête d'habitants
aujourd'hui il est à 35 et donc la
déconsommation des vins rouges en France
c'est normal parce que le vin est devenu
culture et non plus une boisson et à
côté de ça il va falloir que lorsqu'on
regarde l'export et pour parler de tout
ce que je venais de dire à Michel
Chapoutier on va aller chez vous
Florence lasarade pour débuter ce débat
on va parler de la crise qui traverse le
vignoble bordelais frappé par une
surproduction des petits viticulteurs
n'arrivent plus à vendre tout leur vin
rouge alors qu'il représente 80% du
vignoble les syndicats de la profession
essayent d'obtenir des aides de l'État
pour les aider à s'en sortir dans
l'Entre-Deux-Mers et à Bordeaux on
regarde ce reportage de Jonathan du
Priest
Bastien Mercier est fier de son Bordeaux
rouge celui-ci on est sur le 2021 4 fois
médaillée d'or au concours de Paris Lyon
Mâcon Bordeaux
et c'est du vin que l'on a du mal à
vendre parce que 2021 ne bénéficient pas
d'une belle réputation d'année alors
qu'elle est qualitative tout mis les
inconfus 6000 hectolitres stockés dans
ces cuves ne trouvent pas preneur
l'équivalent de 800000 bouteilles comme
d'autres vignerons de la région Bastien
produit trop de rouge alors que la
demande a fortement baissé covid marcher
chinois en berne quant à la consommation
des Français est la chuté d'un tiers en
10 ans la grande partie de la population
en effet se concentre sur les blancs les
rosés les crémants qui sont aujourd'hui
vraiment à la mode et donc bien sûr les
rouges sont un peu plus délaissés un des
amours des rouges qui a plongé Bastien
Mercier en situation critique placé en
redressement judiciaire son exploitation
accuse un million d'euros de dettes
seule solution pour lui arracher des
vignes contre une prime de l'État on
prévoit de diviser par 3 la production
de l'exploitation donc nous étions à 65
hectares nous avons lâché environ 19
hectares de fermage et on veut en
arracher autant
pour pour éviter de continuer à faire
des frais cet arrachage primé Frédéric
carrino 65 ans le réclame lui aussi
faute de quoi il ne pourra pas partir à
la retraite je scrute pas l'horizon je
scrute l'avenir la crise de
surproduction du vignoble bordelais a
aussi fait chuter fortement le prix des
terres viticoles Frédéric possède 19
hectares de vignes qui ne valent
quasiment plus rien or il tablait sur la
vente de ces terres pour compenser une
très mince retraite agricole de 550
euros à l'heure actuelle si on a des
propositions sérieuses on est plutôt sur
la base de la dernière transactions sur
la base 6000 euros l'hectare alors que
il y a six sept ans de ça à 25000 euros
l'hectare
n'importe quelle ligne par quel esprit
là quoi autrefois on avait un capital de
sortie qui nous permettait de compenser
le manque à gagner par rapport à la
retraite aujourd'hui c'est retraite
faible et capitales zéro derrière les
vignerons l'interprofession des vins de
Bordeaux porte faire pour obtenir des
aides d'urgence auprès du gouvernement
appuyé par les vignobles de Loire du
Rhône le syndicat du Bordelais espère
obtenir de l'État 10000 euros par
hectare de Vignard haché mais aussi des
aides à la distillation des surplus
d'alcool pour réguler le marché arracher
une vigne ou détruire du vin que l'on a
produit c'est c'est un racheteur pour
pour les vignerons c'est juste de la
régulation économique qui est difficile
à mettre en place mais qui permettent à
des entreprises de se sauver de passer
un mauvais cap de restructurer leur
entreprise si l'avenir est incertain
pour ces vignerons pierre de rock
feuille ne baisse pas les armes le jeune
viticulteur a repris l'exploitation
familiale depuis 10 ans et s'est lancé
dans une diversification de sa
production
pour rendre le bordeaux plus attractif
et en changer le goût il a planté du
Malbec un cépage peu courant dans les
assemblages de vins de Bordeaux le
malvêque c'est pour pour changer les
profils des vins on est sur des vins on
va rechercher des vins épicés
des vins
goulillants et puis pour voilà pour pour
tester autre chose parce que on se rend
bien compte que le Merlot à outrance
aujourd'hui on a du mal à le vendre donc
il faut trouver des nouvelles idées pour
Pierre le vignoble bordelais doit
progressivement se remettre au niveau du
goût du consommateur c'est le
consommateur qui fait le produit
disait nous ici la propriété ça a
commencé à vraiment marcher
à partir des quand les baby-boomers sont
arrivés sur le marché de la consommation
ils s'en vont ça marche moins bien il
faut trouver la boisson qui plaît à la
nouvelle génération paradoxe de la crise
les grands crus du Bordelais sont
épargnés ces fleurons du luxe à la
française pèse 60% des exportations de
Bordeaux à terme il pourrait être amené
à contribuer pour aider les viticulteurs
les plus en difficulté
voilà pour ce sujet qui pose beaucoup de
questions évidemment on va y revenir
tout au long de ce club d'abord on le
voit Florence la Sarrade trop de rouge
pas assez de consommation est-ce que le
vignoble bordelais est en crise
aujourd'hui oui je pense que le la
fermeture du marché chinois en
particulier avec le covid ça a été le
révélateur de la crise il y a plus la
Chine on vend plus sur les Français
n'ont plus forcément appétence pour ce
vin rouge qui qui je le disais avait
Michel Chapoutier et de plus en plus
puissant donc il y a aussi ce problème
mais c'est vrai que l'autre jour j'étais
dans le Médoc voir quelques mères quand
on est à Saint-Julien beychevel à
Margaux on a vraiment pas le même son de
cloche que quand je suis dans
l'Entre-Deux-Mers chez moi par exemple
Bastien Mercier que je connais bien moi
j'ai simplement un moment dit il y a un
cri d'alarme des viticulteurs je suis
allé à une réunion en juin 2022 où
200 viticulteurs c'était vraiment
réuni pour garder l'arrachage pour
réclamer l'arrachage et il y avait une
ambiance quasiment suicidaire dans la
salle donc il faut quand même prendre ce
prendre ces cas en compte ça veut pas
dire que l'interprofession globalement
va mal le vignoble de Bordeaux garde son
côté prestigieux va bien mais il y a
quand même une comment dire pas une
viticulture de vitesse mais une
adaptation au marché qui doit se faire
et peut-être comme le disait pierre de
Roquefeuille adapté aussi le le prévenir
on va y venir mais au goût du au goût du
consommateur c'est le consommateur
finalement qui doit guider on doit pas
forcément rester sur des sur des des
choses trop contraignantes ça veut dire
qu'il faut changer pour les viticulteurs
il faut qu'il change leur manière de
faire du vent
pas forcément la manière que si vous
prenez la toutes les médailles que tu as
eu Bastien Mercier sur les salons ou
autre c'est un vin qui est excellent
mais il faut peut-être vérifier plus il
fait du crémant et aux attentes des
consommateurs juste déjà regardons
comment a évolué la consommation
regardez la jeune génération votre
génération
vous êtes des personnes qui avaient
appris à déguster des produits doit
boire des produits qui sont sortis du
frigo
d'où l'explosion des blancs avoir des
produits sodas donc d'où l'explosion
d'où l'explosion des produits des fermer
sens c'est à dire l'écrivant les
cocktails qui sont tous gazeux et les
cocktails et le rouge alors le rosé par
la place place importante qui est en
train de se tasser mais le rouge quand
vous dit toujours mais le rouge en glace
que j'en ai nombreuses c'est un
sacrilège on met pas ou dans le gaz et
ça veut dire que le rosé beaucoup de
gens voulaient faire du rosé mais la
Provence qui avait un coup d'avance
garde son leadership et à une approche
presque un peu à La Champenoise très
marques et à côté derrière les gens qui
font du rosé c'est presque de la seconde
division même s'ils sont des mêmes
niveaux de qualité au niveau
reconnaissance client on revient sur le
vin rouge les gens ne veulent pas ne
veulent pas boire c'est à dire le
consommateur qui consomme de tarotte ou
pas boire des des produits à température
d'ambiance de la pièce alors les
Cautionneurs ça ne les dérange pas ils
aiment avoir leurs grands rouges qui
paye cher mais les la population
régionale on parlait de Bordeaux mais
tous les rouges
tous les vins rouges d'appellation
régionale qui sont dans cette gamme là
il y a pas que de la gastronomie il y a
de la bistronomie il y a aussi donc il
faut aussi des vins qui correspondent à
ce marché là donc si on ne peut pas
arracher la mine pour la replanter alors
il va y avoir des obligations
d'arrachage qui vont être nécessaires
vis-à-vis de ces gens qui se sont dans
la grande dans la grande peine mais si
on veut adapter le produit il faut
trouver des moyens d'adapter le produit
sans obliger à restructurer le vignoble
ça coûte 25 à 30 000 euros vous imaginez
ces gens qui ont plantés à 25000 euros
l'hectare qui vendent à 6000 euros
l'hectare c'est inconcevable et donc on
va arriver sur des sur des logiques où
ils font dire le carré le Clairet les
rouges clairs que l'on ose mettre en
place regardez l'Alsace on dit les
rouges se vendent pas en Alsace ils ont
passé le rouge parce que les gens ils
ont pris l'habitude de mettre le pilot
noir en place il y a aucun problème pour
eux la Loire ils ont des rouges qu'ils
savent qu'ils ont écrit au client de
mettre le rouge en glace parce que le
consommateur ne boit pas de rouge parce
que c'est pas qu'il n'a pas le rouge
c'est qu'il ne veut pas boire
température ou alors un vin cher avec
toute la cérémonie du haut de gamme mais
il faut on a besoin dans la pyramide de
ses vins plus simples autrement le monde
du vin va mourir par snobisme donc il
faut laisser une place il faut repenser
il faut repenser mais il faut garder
est-ce qu'il faut rééduquer les
consommateurs aussi il faut ridicule les
consommateurs et la profession parce que
si vous regardez il y avait une pyramide
les vins d'un trait de gamme avec une
place au socle
on a voulu faire des AOC et des AOC des
AOC et au-delà on a une pyramide à
l'envers c'est à dire qu'il faut revenir
sur des vins qui correspondent aux
besoins du consommateur et au prix que
peuvent mettre les consommateurs
le prix quand je vois des AOC a 2
€, ça me choque ça me choque parce que
combien les gens
on n'a qu'à boire un peu moins et puis
il y a le monde entier mais c'est pas
normal de trouver des bouteilles à moins
de 3 euros c'est pas drôle quand vous
voyez tout le prix à mon attitude
l'autre jour et c'est vrai qu'ils ont
frappé les esprits en montant une
bouteille de vinaigre une bouteille de
jus de pomme une bouteille de de
bière qui était toute plus cher que la
bouteille de vin très correcte qui était
à côté
c'est vrai c'est vrai donc
est-ce que moi quand je suis allé
effectivement atteint l'Hermitage j'ai
remarqué que certains niveaux de de vins
prestigieux c'est accepté au prix auquel
il est vendus et ça permet de tirer vers
le haut les prix de la coopérative
voisine également parce que la
coopérative Les coopérative c'est
important aussi en Girondins
réinvestis qui est très dynamique et qui
tire avec elle est pas suiveur elle est
pas dans la logique elle est extrêmement
dynamique l'autre question pose par ce
reportage de Jonathan et c'est
évidemment lui c'est lié pardon c'est la
question de l'arrachage des vignes
arracher les vignes contre une prime de
l'État est-ce que pour vous c'est la
solution Florence
quand on se promène en Gironde je l'ai
fait pas mal pour ma campagne
sénatoriale par exemple je circule il y
a énormément de flavescence dorées c'est
à dire qu'il y a des il y a des friches
il y a des vignes complètement en friche
soit parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
repreneur soit parce que simplement le
vigneron n'a pas les moyens de traiter
on en est là donc je pense que déjà il y
a cet arrachage sanitaire qui est
nécessaire
sinon qui est pas très compliqué par
contre
arraché je pense que on arrive aussi à
un moment où la moitié de viticulteurs
sont pratiquement à l'âge de la retraite
non plus
moyen de revendre il a bien expliqué il
comptait sur cette revente pour vivre de
la retraite parce que les retraites
agricoles sont quand même très faibles
c'était un mécanisme qui n'existe plus
donc certains réclament l'arrachage pour
cette raison mais c'est vrai que quand
on voit combien coûte un plan de vigne à
exploiter et qu'on l'arrache ensuite
pour presque rien c'est un problème ça
peut être une solution sur une petite
partie peut-être 10 % du vignoble
bordelais ce qui a été ce qui a été
planté dans les Paluds dans des zones
qui sont pas forcément beaucoup
d'intérêt après est-ce qu'on n'a pas
marché n'importe quoi on a trop peur
quand on pouvait emprunter emprunter de
l'argent ça rapportait de l'argent là à
l'époque ça a été beaucoup planté quand
je suis arrivé dans la région
pour faire des des Bordeaux structurés
et concentré il y a ce sont peut-être
des terroirs adaptés pour faire des
Bordeaux style clarés c'est à dire que
le principe d'un rouge léger et ça ça
veut dire ça serait une approche je
crois que Bordeaux partage son nom
clarés parce que ça serait une approche
nation sur les appellations régionales
pour lancer un produit
un rouge plus léger qu'on est décomplexé
que l'on met en place c'est sans doute
une piste on avait le Clairette qu'un
sac qui était à la mode
rose et foncé et le rouge vert
quand même très apprécié dans les années
80 qui a complètement perdu sur
larachage du coup Michel qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous la rachat est-ce que
est-ce que ça peut être tout le monde
très réservé et très réservé mais entre
deux mots entre les 160 millions que le
ministre propose de mettre dans la
distillation seulement dans du
conjoncturel en prenant 240 millions
dans la cagnotte qui permet normalement
derrière exporter et de restructurer les
les
outils de production on est plutôt
réservé mais si
tout va sur la distillation ça règle pas
du tout le problème
alors je sais bien à la décharge du
ministre c'est que il cherche les outils
qui permettent de financer le rachage je
crois qu'il y a un problème technique là
dessus
parce que là il s'est incontestable mais
nous notre position au niveau c'est dire
écoutez soyez peut-être un petit peu
plus sévère sur l'approche distillation
parce que si vous l'enveloppe elle n'est
que là et va garder des sous pour le
structurel comme dit à Lafarge et c'est
à dire la logique ça serait quasiment si
on a que 160 millions c'est de faire du
moitié-moitié
donc il va falloir être un peu plus
sévère sur les approches de distillation
et pourra regarder après pour le
structure on va revenir là-dessus
puisque effectivement cette partie des
solutions du gouvernement mais on l'a vu
et vous en avez parlé Florence la
Sarrade dans ce reportage cette
agriculteur qui disait pour compter sur
l'arrachage justement pour compenser sa
main se retraite agricole est-ce que
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
viticulteurs qui ne sont sortent plus et
qui doivent jeter l'éponge
la Chambre d'Agriculture en Gironde a
recensé plus de 1300 agriculteurs en
difficulté dont un tiers en gros
veulent l'arrachage et fermer leur
entreprise c'est c'est à peu près ce qui
a été
[Musique]
oui qui sont au bord de la retraite et
ce qu'on se double problème et qui n'ont
pas le le la reprise la génération
suivante voit quand même leur père dans
le Maras mais ne se sent pas forcément
prêts à tous ces sacrifices c'est un
problème de renouvellement de génération
dans la viticulture
mais dans la vie je pense que il y a un
problème à côté
dans le temps la pyramide des âges on la
connaît et ben moins en moins de
viticulteurs ou d'agriculteurs
compensés par des domaines de plus en
plus grand on arrive à un niveau où les
exploitants ne veulent plus grandir
être plus grand c'est plus de problèmes
c'est problème sociaux c'est des
problèmes de etc et les gens ne veulent
plus avoir des salariés il y a aussi il
y a aussi cette approche là en disant
j'ai mes deux salariés historiques
reprendre le domaine d'à côté je vais
prendre deux salariés plus je veux pas
avoir ce problème là on vous en avez un
peu parlé Michel Chapoutier mais la
filière Marion ça fait longtemps qu'elle
alerte sur ses difficultés des
difficultés qu'elles traversent elles
semblerait enfin être entendue et bien
oui Oriane la négociations sur ce sujet
devrait d'ailleurs aboutir très bientôt
au cours du Salon de l'Agriculture le
gouvernement devrait faire plusieurs
annonces pour aider les vignobles
bordelais et languedocien dans les
grandes lignes ce plan de soutien
apporterait une aide pour tenter
d'éponger le surplus de vin qui stagne
dans les cuves l'idée c'est en fait de
financer la distillation de deux et demi
à 3 d'hectolitres de vin pour le
transformer en alcool pharmaceutique ou
alimentaire c'est ce qu'a indiqué le
secrétaire général de la FNSEA il y a
des aides financières oui un chèque de
160 millions d'euros a également été
promis par le ministre de l'Agriculture
sur l'enveloppe de 200 millions d'euros
que réclamer les professionnels du
secteur enfin concernant l'arrachage des
vignes les primes n'existent plus au
niveau européen mais le gouvernement se
dit prêt à activer deux leviers l'un
pour favoriser la diversification des
cultures ou la mise en jachère pour
accroître la biodiversité l'autre pour
limiter les risques sanitaires liés aux
vignes abandonnées mais toutes ces
modalités restent pour l'instant en
discussion Oriane et aucun montant
d'aide n'a encore été officialisée merci
Marion est-ce que c'est à la hauteur
Florence assarade et je vous fais
évidemment réagir après Michel chapeau
non je crois que enfin bien sûr c'est
déjà un premier pas mais c'est toujours
un crève-cœur on l'a vu déjà pendant le
covid la distillation c'est un
crève-cœur pour les pour les
viticulteurs
l'arrachage on en a on en a parlé
ce qui est important c'est de comme
disait Michel Chapoutier c'est d'aider à
la commercialisation c'est ça ces pistes
et se pencher sur ce que veut le
consommateur je crois que c'est c'est
également intéressant parce que chaque
crise va amener des demandes de
distillation on en est pas la première
on n'est pas la dernière et je pense pas
les chaises sont pleins là on a deux à
trois ans de récolte dans les chaînes
donc forcément faut trouver une solution
mais c'est une solution immédiate c'est
pas une solution à long terme je pense
qu'il faut regarder également vers le
long terme
oui vous avez actuellement on a eu une
distillation sur 2020 déjà 260 millions
d'euros derrière on a eu une année de
gel donc 2021 n'est pas une grosse année
et on est en train de repartir sur une
destination on va le faire tous les deux
ans ou tous les trois ans
il est certain que le structurel la
question doit être sur le structurel et
non pas sur le sur le conjoncturel mais
la vraie question est de dire qu'est-ce
qu'on l'ont fait est-ce qu'on va faire
tout ça ou enfin on se pose des vraies
questions que veut le marché comment
devant nous nous adapter il faut que les
gens soient beaucoup plus dynamique pour
se tourner vers l'exportation vous avez
aujourd'hui de l'exportation est-ce que
les vins français et continuent de bien
se vendre à l'étranger il se vendent
même mieux que bien mieux que bien après
il faut il faut aussi dans le segment
des AOC les appellations régionales
prenez Bordeaux régional Côtes-du-Rhône
où toutes ces appellations régionales
doivent avoir un statut intermédiaire
avec une souplesse au niveau des cahiers
des charges on parlait d'exemples de
Bordeaux la Chine
on va laisser ça à nos collègues
espagnols et italiens ou des
appellations régionales pourraient avoir
cette dérogation de mettre juste trois
quatre grammes de sucre pour
correspondre vous avez tout un tas de
capacités l'un des alcoolisations va se
poser le problème moi je serai pas
choqué que les appellations d'origine
contrôlée au niveau régional donc les
grandes volumétriques puissent dire nous
on peut partiellement des alcooliser
l'ovins pour correspondre donc il faut
pas faut sortir de nos dogmes et surtout
il faut se bouger parce que c'est sous
la si on nous les avait donné pour aller
exporter je peux vous dire qu'on
n'aurait pas ces problèmes aujourd'hui
c'est je rappelle que les taxes Trump
l'État a donné 0 à la 0 0 ça coûtait un
milliard à la filière et l'État n'a rien
donné et aujourd'hui alors
oui c'est pareil au niveau des aides de
la Pâques on n'a pas Ted quand on fait
le salon de Wayne Paris un très gros
salon qui va devenir probablement le
plus gros salon des vins on devrait
avoir à peu près tous les exposants
parce que ça va devenir le plus gros
salon au monde du vin c'est le premier
pas pour aller l'exporter parce que ça
permet à moindre coût d'avoir une
multitude de contacts le futur c'est pas
la France on va continuer à voir le
futur c'est l'exportation et
l'exportation nous attend mais il faut y
aller et un mot rapidement là-dessus
avoir une dernière question Florence
Assad sur l'exportation parce qu'on
entendait dans le reportage de Jonathan
dire que les fleurons des vins bordelais
et ils ne sont pas touchés ils sont
moins touchés en tout cas par les
problèmes et ce sont eux qui s'exportent
mais tout le monde s'exporte là ça
commence à frémir côté chinois en
espérant exporter c'est un très gros
marché donc les fleurons ils sont
constamment là mais les petits
peuvent y aller aussi quand c'est ouvert
mais c'est vrai que si la Chine ferme
régulièrement c'est un sujet ne par la
Russie
que les secteurs qui ont investi très
tôt dans les nôtres ne sont généralement
pas en difficulté même à Bordeaux j'ai
fait un tour à Bordeaux avec Bordeaux
tourisme de
différents et on s'est rendu compte que
ces gens-là étaient beaucoup moins
touchés parce que les notorismes et
aussi une voix qui va falloir défendre
c'est à dire c'est un circuit court
c'est de la manteau particulier et c'est
de la vente pour aider la filière il
faut apprendre à vendre cher ok déjà
accepte à payer le prix d'un produit un
dernier mot Florence assassin et Michel
chapitre puisqu'on parlait de l'avenir
on parlait de la diversification de la
production pour répondre aux attentes
des consommateurs mais est-ce que dans
la diversification de la production il
va aussi falloir tenir compte du
réchauffement climatique est-ce que ça
repense complètement les vignobles et
notamment le vignobles bordelais le
problème c'est que tout le monde arrive
à faire du vin même maintenant en
Angleterre ou en Suède donc sur le
marché européen par exemple ça va
forcément limiter les consommations
de vin aborder c'est sûr mais on a un
problème de sécheresse qui qui limite
les rendements
on peut pas arroser un vin en AOC alors
que les vins en IGP peuvent bénéficier
de l'arrosage mais ce qui
je reviens sur le degré d'alcool il
monte on a quand même des difficultés à
contenir c'est sur les mêmes sur les
vins rouges les vins blancs aussi c'est
ça c'est ça le problème de réchauffement
climatique
tolérant et ouvert aux nouvelles
techniques de désalcoolisations
climatique ça va repenser la viticulture
sur le sur le mode de travail
l'irrigation sera incontournable mais
l'irrigation c'est pas forcément le
pompage l'irrigation personnellement
j'ai cinq vignobles en Australie c'est
beaucoup plus sacrifié et on a toujours
travaillé sur la captation des eaux de
pluie et lorsque vous avez de plus en
plus d'épisodes cévenols avec des
grosses pluies réellement en même temps
quand vous captez les eaux de pluie vous
protégez en aval les villes donc le
problème d'eau qu'on arrête de dire que
l'agriculture vole toute l'eau les
bassines c'est incontournable et le
futur de l'agriculture merci beaucoup
pour ce débat merci d'avoir été avec
nous vous restez avec nous si vous
voulez bien on va regarder ce qu'elle a
une de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]